bonjour avec six poulains merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin en direct sur
rt france alors on a entendu olivier
viron dire qu'il sentait bien que
finalement les soignants avaient bien
envie de se faire vacciner vous comment
vous expliquez ce pod en train de
certains soignants à elle faire se peut
dans le train il vient sans doute aussi
des messages contradictoires qui ont été
donnés un par les autorités
rappelez-vous début janvier c'est
emmanuel macron le président de la
république lui-même a soi-disant avec
son son pitch dit d'épidémiologistes qui
disait à la presse anglaise que le
vaccin astrazeneca ne marchait pas trop
pour les plus âgés ad - d'efficacité
puis c'est philippe alain fischer pardon
le monsieur vaccin du gouvernement qui
lui disait finalement on va arrêter de
vacciner les soignants parce qu'il y
avait eu des cas de vaccination où il ya
vu des réactions assez forte de
soignants qui avait reçu ce vaccin est
donc on va arrêter et toutes les
messages en fait qui ont été données par
le gouvernement était assez
contradictoire et puis il faut rattraper
le retard on se rend compte que
finalement les doses astrazeneca reste
dans les frigos alors maintenant il faut
faire machine arrière et vacciné vous
s'il vous plaît faites quelque chose est
plutôt que le s'il vous plaît et bien
que fait le gouvernement
qu'est-ce qui sait faire le mieux
contraindre agité la menace est là c'est
attention si vous ne le faites pas on va
le rendre obligatoire ce vaccin donc on
peut comprendre que les soignants en ai
marre des injonctions contradictoires
qu'ils ne savent pas vraiment où aller
alors après il ya une différence entre
les médecins qui sont à 70% quasiment
pour le vaccin qui se sont fait vacciner
pour beaucoup les aides-soignants et les
infirmiers qui eux sont entre 30 et 20 %
à vouloir se faire vacciner
il ya aussi bien entendu dans les
mémoires l'histoire de la vaccination
obligatoire contre l'hépatite b qui
était très mal passé à l'époque et c'est
vrai que les soignants il y a un an
il fallait les applaudir à la fenêtre
c'est lé héros il était en première
ligne de cette guerre contre le coc vide
en première ligne avec des sacs en
plastique comme blues avec pas assez de
masques puisqu'il y avait le fiasco des
masques à l'époque pas du tout aidé il
était effectivement eu en première ligne
il ya eu beaucoup de morts dans le
personnel soignant et et chez les
médecins
et aujourd'hui il faudrait les montrer
du doigt et dire que c'est leur faute si
on attrape la comida l'hôpital je crois
que ça suffit de diviser les populations
de manière aussi grotesques ils savent
très bien ce qu'il faut faire
les soignants ils sont responsables il
ya les gestes barrière il ya toutes les
protocoles qui sont mises en place au
sein des hôpitaux
et puis ils attendent simplement des
preuves que oui la vaccination permet de
ne pas transmettre le virus aujourd'hui
on attend toujours de savoir on sait que
ça réduit les cas graves que ça permet
de désengorger les hôpitaux c'est
l'exemple israélien qui le montrent
notamment pour les plus âgés qui évite
d'être hospitalisé pour le reste on
attend de voir si le gouvernement
peut-il rendre la vaccination
obligatoire c'est toute la ligne de
crête sur laquelle repose aujourd'hui le
gouvernement on voit bien qu'ils
essayent de rendre un maximum de choses
obligatoire avec la en flirtant avec la
limite de la légalité
olivier véran ministre de la santé qui
disait face à un interviewer sur une
radio que les résidents d pad pour en
sortir une fois qu'ils seront vaccinés
ça n'a aucune base légale c'était un
scandale d'ailleurs retoquée par le
conseil constitutionnel qui dit on se
calme on ne peut pas dire des choses
pareilles quand on est ministre
donc on voit bien que le gouvernement
aimerait mettre des coups de canifs 1 au
pacte de la démocratie libérale pour
obliger les français obligés par exemple
les résidents d pad à se vacciner oblige
les soignants à se vacciner
et puis l'étape d'après c'est bien sûr
obliger tous les français à se vacciner
y compris les plus jeunes
donc la question qui se pose en fait
c'est bien sûr celle de la volonté
et puis ça voudrait dire remettre en
cause la parole du chef de l'état qui
avait dit que non en france clairement
la vaccination ne sera pas obligatoire
et c'est d'ailleurs vaccination non
obligatoire est réaffirmée dans les
textes européens
même s'il parle bien sûr de passeports
inverse de passeports numériques
vaccinaux en disant qu'ils ne sont pas
liés à une vaccination obligatoire donc
on est en train de voir les limites
finalement du droit avec cette envie de
rentrer beaucoup de choses obligatoire
contre l'avis des français et contre
l'avis des législateurs on l'a vu ce
week end un olivier ferrand et jean
castex tous azimuts pour promouvoir
justement les vaccinations massives
ce sera le cas on met ce que c'est
réalisable pour vous et pour quels
publics sur tout
alors le l'objectif est imposante 30
millions de français vaccinés avant
l'été donc les chiffres changent tous
les quinze jours on n'arrive plus
vraiment à suivre sur les geôles sur le
nombre de personnes sur les publics
concernés également on agrandirait les
publics qui auraient droit à la
vaccination au delà des plus âgés des
personnes à la comorbidité toute cette
campagne finalement mené pas d'une main
de maître mais qu'un cas par les
cabinets de conseil qui sont mckeen's
est bonne et les autres payés par le
ministère de la santé pour organiser ce
fiasco vaccinale bien ils attendent
simplement crédoz soit livré parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est bien beau de sortir
des chiffres mais tout dépend du nombre
de doses qui seront livrés et de
l'autorisation de nouveaux vaccins
notamment cure bac et d'autres qui
attendent l'autorisation pour être mises
sur le marché
donc là ça dépend bien sûr d'astrazeneca
c'est pour ça que on va vider les frigos
il ya les colères des manuels macron
dans les conseils de défense on disait
en tant que vous aurez pas vider les
frigos il appelle n'est pas question de
desserrer la vis sur les couvre feu à 18
heures et ce genre de truc qu'on fait le
week end dans le nord pas de calais ou
ailleurs
donc on voit bien que maintenant si les
doses arrive eh bien on va les injecter
le plus vite possible
le but du jeu c'est un sprint avant
l'été pour vacciner un maximum de monde
possible et voir si éventuellement ça
marche avec les beaux jours arrivant
évidemment le virus lui aussi sera moins
virulent comme comme ça a été le cas
l'an dernier
merci beaucoup alexis poulain votre
édito on le retrouve sur les réseaux
sociaux bien évidemment et on retrouve
lundi prochain pour l'édito de la
matinale merci